(تم転사 بواسطة TurboScribe.ai. انتقل إلى Unlimited لإزالة هذه الرسالة.) اسمي الأستاذ براون وهذا
فيديو لدرس اللغة لصفّي الثاني
خلال فترة عزل كورونا في كوماياغوا، هندوراس.
مرحباً بالجميع، أتمنى أن تكونوا جميعاً
سعداء وأنكم تغسلون أيديكم.
هدفنا اليوم هو تهجئة الأفعال الشائعة
ونطقها بشكل صحيح من خلال مشاهدة عرض الشرائح
وكتابة الكلمات معاً.
هل يعرف أحدكم ما هو الفعل؟
الفعل هو كلمة تدل على عمل أو حركة.
هل تتذكرون عندما لعبنا لعبة 'Simon Says'؟ (لعبة الأوامر)
قبل بضعة أسابيع؟
نعم؟
ما هي بعض الكلمات التي تعلمتموها
من لعبة 'Simon Says'؟ (لعبة الأوامر)
إليكم بعض ما أتذكره.
Play, walk, run, eat, jump, stomp, clap,
drink, read, write, sit, close, open.
هل تعرفون كلمات أخرى؟
هل تتذكرون المزيد؟
دعونا نتدرب معاً على المزيد.
سأستمع إلى نطقكم لاحقًا.
لهذا النشاط، ستحتاجون إلى قلم رصاص
وقطعة من الورق.
شاهدوا الصور واكتبوا الكلمة المناسبة
للصور التي ترونها.
عندما تفهمون الصور، ستتمكنون
من لعب لعبة تواصل مع زملائكم
في الصف.
دعونا نقوم بهذا النشاط معاً أولاً.
حسناً، رقم واحد هو clap, clap (يصفق - yuṣaffiqu),
هكذا.
رقم اثنين، رقم اثنين هو close (يغلق - yughliqu),
close, هكذا.
رقم ثلاثة، رقم ثلاثة هو drink (يشرب - yashrabu), drink,
drink, drink.
رقم أربعة هو eat (يأكل - yaʾkulu),
eat, eat, eat.
رقم خمسة هو jump (يقفز - yaqfizu), j-u-m-p.
J-u-m-p, j-u-m-p.
رقم ستة هو open (يفتح - yaftaḥu), o-p, open,
open.
رقم سبعة، play (يلعب - yalʿabu / يعزف - yaʿzifu), p-l-a-y.
رقم ثمانية، رقم ثمانية هو read (يقرأ - yaqraʾu), r-e
-a-d, read.
رقم تسعة، رقم تسعة هو run (يجري - yajrī), n
-r-u-n.
رقم عشرة هو sit (يجلس - yajlisu), s-i
-t, ليس e, ليس seat, s-i-t,
sit.
رقم أحد عشر، أحد عشر هو stomp (يدب بقدمه - yadubbu bi-qadamih), s-t,
stomp.
رقم اثنا عشر هو walk (يمشي - yamshī), walk.
هذا الحرف لا يُنطق، walk.
الأخير، رقم ثلاثة عشر، ثلاثة عشر، write (يكتب - yaktubu), write.
هذا الحرف لا يُنطق، write.